if I’m joking the house etude or
you put it that you will already make a noise
from this, everything you gave will wash off
each payment although 150 for 3 didn’t wait for
between on your soiled itself would
still be there it turns out 300 meters there
it was possible 800 for 3 on how to end it  I’ll say
it easier how you want to break out 2 not a snitch,
well, there
will be an attack from us
there is no one side,
I think that she can start with and
it’s possible and then naturally
on the one hand he and we can she and
I wanted it to start so that God
is already a talker, let people
don’t  Ruzin and even then such smart ones were found,
you think it’s to give
voice acting that the tsar has become
given, maybe purists and come on, maybe
Palestine still understands that the farther
we go for you, this
swamp is
figuratively all the swamps and again for them
there will be Ukraine there he is and what to tie a
famine and  not all people were swept out of the
lidka here we will be a year already close to the
shooter tail exactly under Alec, as
I understand it in the MRM regiment rebata we don’t
know what someone’s running and the tank and the miracle are and
here it turns out
so I’m joking then and after the blue position it all
happened so also anti-lacquer art
mortars and ivashki well and eighty at night
punish his strength the
platform is still 14 and 15 volunteers
then you can try to find yourself
at home rick it turned out and I pulled the jig
magnet on the
channel here  turik will mapo-gu didn’t
work out especially didn’t
come it yet